foreign
a hundred thousand Americans every year
are having their children 200 000
because it's both parents right
are having their children taken away
from them
this should not be politicized it's not
about race fennel doesn't care about
race this is a war
act like it do something
all right uh that was Rebecca kiesling
testifying in Congress yesterday about
the heartbreaking impact of fentanyl on
her family as both her sons passed away
our sons are 18 and 20 years old their
pills that they took were laced with
this deadly drug one and done and where
is fentanyl coming from how does it get
here and what is the objective in
bringing it here why are so many
Americans dying so let's take a look all
right first off it's manufactured for
the most part uh in China now from China
the the conventional wisdom is that it
goes to Mexico the cartelso profit off
it it'll be pressed inside neighborhoods
and sent to the U.S however we're
finding out it does go directly from
China into the U.S and now we're seeing
two China into India and then right over
through the U.S and what happens is it's
also put into neighborhoods
neighborhoods where it's done where you
never would think that there's legal
drug use there that's where it's being
actually processed before it gets sold
let's move ahead and let's talk about
what else he could tell you about it
this is what they look like now that is
fentanyl that is pressed that's ready to
go here's the Insidious part of it when
it's laced you think you're getting
Ritalin you think you're getting
Percocet you think you're getting
Oxycontin maybe for pain that you took
when you had a knee operation wow I
still need that let me do that I have a
test coming up let me get Ritalin to
help me concentrate which people use for
ADD but you bought it from somebody that
sold it to you not from a pharmacy not
from a doctor and then it's laced one
and done these are people that for the
most part you don't say well they were
addicted to heroin it went on for years
we couldn't get them off it we couldn't
get her off it this is what happens no I
took it once to study for a test and I
don't survive and here's the crazy thing
they decided to make it look like candy
that you might get a convenience store
so if you're a young person 12 years old
you see those colors you see how it's
disguised you say why not try it and
lastly in terms of the ultimate danger
take a look this is some of the the how
it's smuggled across our border
oftentimes put into tires put into
trunks put into people this is the
result 200 000 of dead you just heard
Miss Riesling talk about that and
Fentanyl accounts for 64 of all drug
related deaths put it on uh put it by
the way uh behind cocaine heroin this is
the number one cause and it doesn't mean
you use it for years years and years and
that you're indeed addicts so what is it
like when fentanyl infects your life
let's bring in uh Rebecca kiesling you
just saw a sound bite from her testimony
yesterday lost two sons the prime of
their lives poisoned she testified in
front of the house committee on Tuesday
to hopefully get the message across to
Democrats and Republicans Rebecca so sad
that you have to experience this what
struck me also is for the most part you
knew nothing about fentanyl right
yeah I had no idea what it was I heard
the you know opiate epidemic and I
thought it was people getting pain meds
and they were getting addicted and then
um you know destroying their lives and
they weren't able to work like I didn't
know that it was anything that was
killing people I knew like of course
heroin killed but
um I didn't know what fentanyl was I
didn't know what Narcan was
and Narcan used to try to revive people
who were caught with feneline uh
fentanyl now with fentanyl in the case
with your sons that was laced correct
into what drug
I don't even use the term light because
there was no Percocet in it it was all
fentanyl my son kainer had four times
sorry five times the amount that was
enough to kill him
I mean these are murder pills it's not
laced it they're just murder pills right
but they thought they were taking
Percocet which is a painkiller
yes and the presses that are coming from
China are able to wrap
to look exactly like the real thing
Rebecca when you told people when people
in your neighborhood when your friends
and family found out about it what was
their reaction to the circumstances that
led to the death of your sons
well I mean it was a shocking
circumstance because there were three
young people who all died at once and
turns out there was another child in my
hometown who died the same day but it
didn't make the news because his story
wasn't Sensational and
um it's rare that these stories actually
make the news so I had no idea what was
happening around me I've met many other
parents from my community who lost their
children
um in the year or two leading up to my
son's death I never heard about it and
lastly there are 150 uh plus U.S
overdose debts every day from synthetic
opioids like fentanyl if not fentanyl
specifically what do you hope comes out
of this interview your testimony and uh
from here from what you now know about
this
well I was
so sorced at the board the boy need to
have
to actual we don't and it was really
disheartening to see the Democrats
um saying that there's fear-mongering
going on like really over a hundred and
ten thousand are dying every year now
drug deaths in America you know I'm
fear-mongering we have reason to be
afraid we're at War do something and and
you know they're they're using a false
narrative that 91 percent are coming
through you know
um ports like points of Entry
when they don't want to face the fact
that they're coming over our open
borders and that the policies are
causing this problem we've had 22
increase in fentanyl deaths between 2020
and 2021 since Biden
um opened the borders you know he it
there's a problem with their failed
policies and they think when they make a
big apprehension they think they solve
the problem it's just a small sample of
what they're missing and Rebecca we're
going to continue to talk to you we'll
continue to push forward on this uh if
you think school shootings are bad they
pale in comparison in terms of numbers
of fatalities to this and if America is
pretty alerted to that Rebecca thanks so
much
thank you I'm so sorry what happened to
your sons too I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis